all right we are now live for stoic
sunday
number two and we started out last week
with or not last week last month talking
about the four virtues
so
today we're going to do a deeper dive
into one of the virtues in particular
and that is the
virtue of wisdom
or practical wisdom or prudence however
you want to call it what i'm going to do
i've got some some remarks prepared
and i'll talk for a while you can put
stuff into the chat if you want to but i
probably won't get to the chat until we
get to the discussion
and q a
portion of this and we're going to do
deep dives like this on each of the four
cardinal stoic virtues wisdom justice
courage temperance
and as it turns out the stoics actually
have a lot more to say about these
things other than you know they're good
and you should have them so let's jump
right into talking about this the virtue
of wisdom has a really really central
role you could say even more central
than the other three virtues in stoicism
and a number of stoic authors
will talk about this and reference it
and it's partly because the term and
idea of wisdom
is
actually covering two different
things that overlap and intersect which
we'll talk about in a moment but these
are the sort of things that i think
people
who you know hear this and they're like
yeah wisdom that sounds good i mean
philosophy is supposed to be about
wisdom they they usually usually get
questions about so we're going to
delve into these
one is the relationship between wisdom
and philosophy as such which the stoics
do talk about
wisdom in its relationship to the other
virtues
the sage the wise person right is an
ideal for stoicism as well as for other
philosophies of life in the ancient
period so we've got to clarify
what the relationship between the virtue
of wisdom and the wise person is a
little bit and then we've got to talk
about wisdom and practical wisdom
as one of these virtues what does it
consist in what does it cover what does
it include and so we're going to look at
quite a few
different passages
and before we do that i want to start
out with just a few
little
these might be helpful for you
um you know sort of charting the way
types of of things
so in greek there are two main terms
that get translated as wisdom or as
prudence or practical wisdom
sophia is one of them right which has
been turned into a a person's name uh
meaning you know the wise one and
phronesis and phronesis comes from you
know this entire vocabulary of like
thinking words
and these are often used interchangeably
so if you're reading platonic dialogues
for example
socrates will sometimes use one word
sometimes use another word they're not
different from each other
in plato really aristotle will
distinguish the two of these but
aristotle is dividing up philosophy
and he's got a different anthropology
uh so he's dividing up philosophy
differently and he's got a different you
know
understanding of the human soul then the
stoics do so we don't want to follow
aristotle here the stoics are not
aristotelian in that respect
in latin there's really three terms that
get used sapientia is corresponding to
the latin sulfur to the greek sophia and
though sometimes they'll just use sophia
in there but then there's also this
prudencia which is sort of a rendering
of phronesis so we got a lot of
vocabulary floating around are the
stoics entirely consistent in their use
of these no
and we don't have to be super super
concerned about that but it is good to
know that there are these different
terms out there in english how do we
translate these well wisdom is a popular
way sometimes we say practical wisdom
when we're referencing
prudencia or phronesis we also use the
word prudence
one text
even uses intelligence which i don't
think is a particularly good translation
of uh prudencia or phronesis
but you're stuck with the translations
that you got
so
as usual if we want to understand what
the stoics really think about this
you've got a couple options right
you can go to modern
popularizers or academic interpreters of
the stoics which would include me and
you can you know take what they have to
say
um or
you can you know do what you really
ought to do
uh the smart thing to do the wise thing
to do and that is to go back to classic
stoic texts because
if modern day interpreters are any good
they're constantly going back to the
original sources
and seeing what these people
had to say
you know and you don't know who's
actually really that that reliable until
you
check them against the the classic
sources so what what classic sources
what classic texts are we talking about
here we got the you know um big three
late roman thinkers seneca epictetus
they're really helpful on this marcus
aurelius i think is good to look at as
well then we also have musonius rufus
who i'm going to talk about a little bit
we've got heracles the stoic
you know so we've got these these late
roman stoics and that's great
but there's also two really important
summaries of stoic doctrine which are
not written by stoics and i mentioned
these in the last session diogenes lair
tastes lives of the philosophers book
seven is devoted entirely to the stoics
and in the very first chapter of that
the life of zeno he's got a great
digression where he's like you know
since i'm talking about xeno i'm talking
about these stoics let me tell you what
it is that these people believe you know
and he summarizes what he takes to be
the stoic doctrine same thing is
happening in aries didymus sometimes
mistakenly called stobayus because arius
didymus's works are found in johannes
stobbaeus's much larger collection but
arius didymus's epitome of stoic ethics
also tells us about these virtues as
well and then we've got this guy who i'm
a huge fan of and i hope that some of
you become fans of as well marcus
tullius cicero right who is not a stoic
himself but who is very very interested
in and influenced by
stoicism he even says at one point if i
was not an academic i would be a stoic
and some of his works are really really
helpful and fill in a lot of missing
information that we otherwise
wouldn't have so that's some background
stuff um
the the next thing that i'm going to
talk about the big uh sort of topic
why do we need wisdom where does it come
from you know is it is it something
that's like an add-on to us or is it
something that's essential
for human beings and the stoics
think that wisdom itself
develops out of our distinctively human
nature the kind of animals rational
animals that we are even before we are
particularly rational we're being driven
towards wisdom and the things that
wisdom
engages with so cicero in his book on
the ends where he's having cato the
great stoic philosopher statesman and
military leader talking um cato says
that
that all beings that are sentient have
self-consciousness or affection if
you've heard of oikiosis this is that
idea it's just not being called that
and it includes cognitions cognizio
right comprehensions in latin
comprehension perceptions
catalapses all of these things are
different ways of talking about what it
is that our brains what it is that our
minds are doing and he goes on to say
that these embrace and contain the truth
and that we've got a sort of innate
drive
to discover things and he he talks about
two different levels in which this takes
place now children
by their very nature are pretty curious
monsters aren't they if anybody's ever
babysat or let alone had a
toddler you know your job is basically
to keep them from killing or maiming
themselves and why is that because they
get into everything right because
they're curious they want to know about
things they enjoy learning
and you know until maybe somebody screws
things up for them in terms of their
education or moral development but
children naturally do enjoy learning
things now
do other animals also enjoy that yes and
we can talk about that in a bit but when
we get to the second level of what what
cicero is calling the sciences ski nti
that is sort of disciplinary bodies of
knowledge about things
um that's something distinctive to human
beings you know the fact that you and i
are talking right now about stoicism and
philosophy
that's not something that elephants or
crows or octopi or other you know highly
intelligent species are doing and it is
it's not something that all human beings
are necessarily doing but all human
beings have the potential for for doing
that sort of thing and they are by
nature
uh interested in learning those those
sorts of things uh he points out another
thing as well in that passage we find
mental assent to the false repugnant
nobody likes being lied to when they
realize uh and it may take a while for
them to realize that they're being lied
to they're usually
upset about it right
in on duties cicero says the search
inquisitio
after truth and its eager pursuit
investigacio in latin are peculiar to
human beings
and he says something else really
interesting here we come to understand
that what is true and simple and genuine
appeals most strongly to a human being's
nature so we've got this kind of natural
drive towards it in on the ends uh cato
again talking he says that we're first
commended to wisdom by the primary
natural instincts from the
initial
beginnings in nature and then afterwards
wisdom itself becomes dearer more
valuable to us than are the instincts
from which we came to her a little bit
later in that passage he's talking about
um
living different kinds of lives and he
says you know just as our bodies aren't
designed for just doing any kind of
activity
our faculty of appetition or choice in
greek gourmet was not designed for just
any old kind of life but for a
particular mode of living and the same
is true of reason
and perfected reason razzio at
perfectorazio the interesting turn of
phrase there for cicero to use right not
just our faculty of rationality but our
faculty of rationality when it's being
developed which is you know how we could
translate perfected
epictetus says uh why did we get reason
from nature
uh well it's to properly use impressions
or
appearances whatever we want to
translate fontasia as and then he says
well what is reason itself and he says
well it's a kind of system sustema of
fontasii so it's naturally
self-contemplative
meaning it looks at itself it it you
know theorem is the greek word for you
know investigating or looking at and
then he says what are the things that
wisdom for onasis has been given to
contemplate things good or bad
things neither good or bad
and so he says you see that wisdom comes
to contemplate itself and it's opposite
so part of what we're doing as we're
thinking about things is thinking about
thinking and thinking about how we go
wrong in thinking and this is leading us
gradually to this virtue
seneca in on leisure
he reminds us that the greatest good is
living in accordance with nature and
what does this mean we are created for
contemplation and action so the
contemplation part is important and he
says you know as human beings we desire
knowledge of the unknown that's why
we're so interested in travelers and
their reports about what it what was it
like over there in egypt what was it
like hanging out with the phoenicians
right we're interested in spectacles
we're interested in digging into each
other's secrets or digging into the
secrets of nature and he says
nature itself has granted us human
beings an inquisitive disposition and he
calls us spectators of the greatest
spectacle if we want to be he says
nature did not just want to be seen
but to be closely observed so we as a
part of nature
are in a kind of privileged position i
mean seneca goes on to talk about how
you know nature made us stand erect so
we can see farther maybe there's
something to that maybe not you know but
we have capacities that allow us to
engage with the world and to engage with
ourselves and to engage with that very
engagement
in a thoughtful
rational
way
so this is where this is the roots
of our capacity for wisdom
so what's wisdom for what are the
functions or what is its scope uh again
you know seneca in on the happy life
says happy is the life that's in
accordance with its own nature and
there's no other there's no other way
for this to come about than if first the
intellect is healthy
and an unending possession of its own
health this is where the the virtue of
wisdom is is going to play
an important role
in on duties uh cicero tells us that
wisdom is concerned with the full
perception and intelligent development
of the true the truth is like the
material that and he uses the word
material in latin that this virtue deals
with
when we look at aries didymus he tells
us that the main functions of wisdom or
intelligence phronesis is to do a couple
things
the first is to
to view and do what must be done in
greek it's theoren right so
contemplating cai prache is a word for
doing activity
ho poieton
what needs to be done
and then to do so in a way where we make
prioritizations
and then he says secondarily
to view what we need to
apportion to divide up
what we need to choose what we need to
endure
in order that we can do
what needs to be done unerringly so that
we we do it the way that we're supposed
to we do it when we're supposed to and
we do it constantly in seneca's letter
90 which i very very highly recommend to
you seneca tells us that
wisdom does a number of different things
and he also says that wisdom doesn't
educate the hand
it educates the mind this is why he'll
tell us that posidonia is the great you
know middle stoic philosopher he's wrong
in thinking that technologies and you
know arts and stuff like that were
discovered by the wise seneca says
wisdom
isn't really concerned with that it does
other things
what does it do he tells us a whole
bunch of things that wisdom does
it keeps the other crafts under its
authority
some of you may you know have like seen
those memes and stuff where it says like
you know knowledge and wisdom here's how
they differ from each other wisdom you
know will will basically tell you how to
use a certain kind of knowledge so for
example is a tomato a fruit right yes a
tomato is a fruit wisdom will tell you
not only you know whether you should put
it in in the food or not but also you
know whether you should argue with other
people about whether tomatoes are fruits
and when you want to do that so keeping
the other crafts under its authority
wisdom is sort of an architect tonic
that is master craftsman craft right and
wisdom is able to look at itself
he also tells us that it has happiness
as its goal and it leads the way for us
and opens the doors for us
it also teaches us
what is good and what is bad
without that we're kind of screwed
aren't we if we don't have a really not
just clear conception because we could
have a loserly clear conception
but an accurate conception of what's
actually good and bad and what's in the
middle and how good and how bad are
things right
he says it also purges our minds of
illusions you know
it has a
role in taking away
things that we think to be knowledge
which actually aren't knowledge which
are misinformation
um
he tells us it gives us a conception of
nature as a whole and also of itself
that is wisdom tells us what wisdom is
because wisdom is
connected to itself in this way
he says it reveals the identity and
attributes of the gods that might be
something that you know we put aside and
we're not quite so worried about but it
was definitely important for the early
stoics
um
uh takes us to the world's origin the
everlasting rationality infused through
the whole the power of all generative
principles the seminoles
the rational principles of everything
that is it investigates the mind in a
variety of different ways and wisdom
scrutinizes the truth and its criteria
and helps us sort out ambiguities so
that is quite a lot of different things
different functions that the virtue of
wisdom
if we're cultivating it ought to be
doing for us now it gets yet more
complex
because the stoics you know for each of
the cardinal virtues they broke those
cardinal virtues down into
sub-virtues right um secondary you could
call them virtues they so they use the
term of you know a capital a head we
call them primary or uh you know
cardinal virtues and then there'd be
these others underneath it
um diogenes liertas tells us that
wisdom is really concerned with um
rational choice he says that the
cologne the beautiful or the good in
itself has four types and he talks about
the four virtues and the way that he
characterizes wisdom is
epistemonicone as knowing as having
knowledge of things but also involving
what we ought to
choose and so he says if a person has
virtue they can figure out and do and
again he uses the words you know
theoretical and practice what ought to
be done
and these things that ought to be done
include what should be chosen and a
bunch of other things
and so
when we can figure that out we can act
with intelligent choice we can
prioritize correctly we can make good
decisions
and so wisdom for him diogenes
lieutenants according to the stoics has
basically two main component parts good
counsel
it's how it's translated as in the lobe
edition
in greek and understanding or sineasis
when we get to areas didymus however
we find that wisdom
includes
six different sub-virtues one of them
has already been mentioned
which gets translated there as soundness
of judgment good counsel soundness of
judgment basically the same thing
that is defined there as knowledge of
what sorts of things and how to do them
right what sort of things we ought to do
how we ought to do them
so that we can act
now it's translated as expediently but
we could say profitably or
usefully or in terms of getting to the
things that we want sum fierontos is the
greek for that
then
he doesn't talk about understanding or
sineasis he talks about five other ones
circumspection eulogistia
knowledge that marks off that that
you know distinguishes and summarizes
soon
kefalayotike in greek right placing
under headings right is is how
summarizing is understood here
um
what is still developing or in process
what is happening to gignoman known and
what is completed what has been brought
to its fulfillment um
then there's a third one shrewdness
ankinoya sort of like having a a
mind you know noya is coming from noose
meaning mind and anki has this this sort
of like closing in but not a narrow mind
rather a mind that's able to focus on
what it's supposed to do
and this is knowledge
as it's defined by the stoics
of um
that's able to discover the
appropriate actor duty so this is very
important for the stoics right they have
this notion of duties of what you ought
to be doing like you know you're your
son you have a father you're supposed to
have certain duties in relation to him
right you have a kid you're supposed to
have certain duties in relation to them
how do you figure this stuff out when it
gets to tricky situations like for
example when sonius rufus talks about
you know your your parent uh tells you
to do something that's actually bad for
them like give them you know food or
drink that they're not supposed to have
you're supposed to obey your parents
that's a duty
what do you do in that circumstance and
it's wisdom that helps you figure out
well giving them the thing they want
wouldn't actually be good for them so
you're not really obeying them in that
sort of circumstance that is shrewdness
or ankinoya and it works in conditions
or situations ektu para
the things that you're surrounded by
right so that's the third one what's the
fourth one
sensibleness
this literally means having a mind
noon
right
noose meaning mind
means you know having uh something so
hold or holding on to it knowledge of
what is worse and what is better now
this is important right so we know that
wisdom includes knowledge of what is
good what is bad what is indifferent
that's nice but we also this is where
things get much more difficult for us in
life right
we need to know what's better
of two goods if we have to choose
between one of them which is the one
that should be preferred
if two things are bad right
which of them is the worst thing this is
something very important to develop and
some people i think do have a conception
of what is good or bad
but they don't do particularly well when
it comes to figuring out what is
better and worse right and then they get
tripped up with that
then we have this thing called soundness
of aim eustochia knowledge that is able
to hit the target that's the way it's
being framed in each case right so being
able to center in on the things that are
relevant or important
and then finally
ingenuity this is a very interesting
term you
makehania right now this is the word
that we get mechanical from may right
knowledge that is able to discover the
way out or through dxodo right hodos is
road and we get the word method from it
in this case we're able to find the way
out of
matters pragmatone it's translated as
difficulties
so you know able to figure out what you
know the way through the situation is
this is what arius didymus says wisdom
encompasses as these six sub
virtues so we've got a lot of stuff
going on here right we've talked about
the scope of wisdom the things that it
extends to the fact that it's it's
self-contemplative
there's a couple other things that i
wanted to bring up that don't fit neatly
into these these categories for example
sony's rufus i think this kind of
illustrates
the application of some of these aspects
or sub-virtues of wisdom he tells us in
his first lecture he's talking about you
know do you need to prove everything all
the time and he says
it is mistaken zeal for the teacher if
he be a true philosopher to rehearse a
multitude of arguments and proofs to his
pupils
he should instead touch on each one with
just measure
seek to penetrate to the very intellect
of his hearer and present persuasive
arguments as and as such cannot be
refuted easily refuted but most of all
so notice
there you know you got to figure out
what kind of learner are you dealing
with and don't overwhelm them with a lot
of stuff give them what it is that they
actually
need in this situation we could apply
this to
not just teaching and learning but
giving counsel to people ruling all
sorts of things like that and then he
says
um his treatment should consist in
showing himself not only as one who
utters words which are most helpful but
as one who acts consistently
with them so
that's important too wisdom is not just
a purely intellectual thing it is
something that you display
in the way that you actually live in how
you treat people how you
handle situations yourself you know
are you are you wise if you can set up a
beautiful class site that students can
explore but when they ask you about
things in emails you don't have
responses
maybe not right so this is an important
aspect too i'll just bring up one other
passage and then we'll start going to
some of these
questions and comments epictetus
tells us that it's really important to
have good judgments dogmata in greek
right or opinions can there's another
way you can translate these
why because these determine so much else
the things that we think
um
those you know generally enter into the
hopper of our mind and wind up through
our reasoning processes and our
volitions determining what it is that we
we think and we do
so
having the mind the dianoya in
accordance with nature is important
and this involves having reason logos
judgments dogmata ascents so in carat
faces
choices hormas desires orexis uh in
accordance with nature and that's the
ideal for epictetus it's not just a
matter of having your pro-racist or
faculty of choice in accordance with
nature you should have all these aspects
in accordance with nature and let's
remember too that in accordance with
nature for stoics does not just mean
like what science reveals to us or the
natural universe it means our
distinctively human nature as properly
developed as fully developed as we can
be
and then he says well if you've got that
then you can take up logical study logos
as a kind of and it's translated in the
lobe edition as hobby uh
philotechnone right is interesting but
what that really means is as a as
something that we
um
enjoy something that we love something
that we desire to to
have you know the techne developed in
and so you know
this is this gives you at least a sense
of what
wisdom encompasses it's not just
something summarized and knowing what's
good or bad right or
being smart or anything like that for
the stoics it covered a whole bunch of
ground and it had to be
developed in all these different parts
and
portions and so that gives us an idea
about what we ought to be doing
as we develop as human beings and the
last thing that i'll say is we want to
be careful
when we're reading the stoics talking
about the sage the sofos the wise person
right
they come along very rarely they
you know say all sorts of really
interesting things about the sage um but
we're all sort of on our way rather than
being sages as seneca points out to us
right we are pro cop toy or
proficientest depending on whether you
like your greek or latin
and that means that
we can be developing this virtue of
wisdom without necessarily having
totally worked it out being at the
highest level being sages
we can become more and more wise right
so this is uh this is something
important i will point out that
sometimes the stoics talk as if virtues
are like an on off switch
i think that's a very unhelpful and
confusing way to talk about the virtues
and and to some degree so does seneca as
well when you look in his works all
right let's let's take so a lot of
people saying uh hello
people are different places it's noon
here for damn albert it's an evening
mark says theoria is apparently as
derived from to spectate and i think
that's a great way to describe that
experience they're talking about it's
like letting things disclose themselves
yeah i mean by the time that we get to
the stoics um
theoria means a lot of different things
so we can we you know when we're looking
at ancient philosophy terms we can go
all heidegger and be like well the
origin of this is is this and that's
nice to know because sometimes that
reveals things to us
but all the other things that it gains
along the way i think is important as
well
so just thinking about is is also
teorillo right
we don't necessarily
have to be like at a spectacle looking
at that
um it can be i mean
the
self-contemplative capacity of our mind
and of the faculty of reason and of the
virtue of wisdom for the stoics is a
prime example of that
um that's a different sense than like to
spectate to to look at something that's
that's uh going on although it could be
connected like you know you're you're
realizing that your emotions are out of
whack or your reasoning processes are
wrong because somebody pointed it out to
you and after you finish being ticked
off with them for for correcting you
you're like oh yeah that's that's what's
happening
um so you know and and the theoria and
um you know prachain the
thinking or
seeing or
paying attention to and then the doing
these are intimately connected with each
other for for the stoics
mark also says it's nice to see such a
rich vocabulary trying to capture this
concept not everything is just about
sophia makes me makes me wonder about
the nuances among meanings of terms we
use in english yeah
i kind of think
that
and you know i i mentioned this a little
bit at the start and i'll i'll sort of
spell this out a little bit more now
that the
uh sophos
uh you know the sage the sophia that
they have we might call capital s sophia
right
and the virtue of um
sophia or for onasis of wisdom that the
stoics are saying is one of the four
that we need which by the way virtue is
you know one thing it's broken down into
four
pieces which then have their own
breakdown into other pieces i would say
that that's you know something the sage
absolutely has but
it's something that we can cultivate
without ourselves trying to be sages
and i think that's that's very important
because so many people get themselves
discouraged
by reading about the sage and by setting
these impossible to reach
um
ideals for themselves in an unwise way i
think so ironically
you know rational wise understanding of
wisdom
is probably going to be
much more directed to what can i
actually make of myself now how can i
become a little bit more intelligent how
can i quit making such dumb decisions
you know as i've been making how can i
improve to some degree it's not it's not
about trying to get to absolute
perfection sagehood
it's instead it's about like how can i
make myself a little bit less screwed up
how can i get back to
something that's closer to what a fully
developed human nature would look like
so
those are good good points and good
questions any other questions about the
topic or the things that we've covered
by anybody
now is the time to weigh in and i'll try
as best as i can
to answer
or address them in the meantime i'll
point out that we are going to do
similar
deep dives uh in the
weeks and months to come so one more
this month and then two next month on
the other three cardinal virtues of
justice
and courage and temperance because the
stoics do in fact have a lot to say
about each of these
and it's very important to get beyond
just mere you know generalities or
abstractions and to talk about what did
they actually have to say
about what justice looks like or you
know what temperance actually consisted
and we're going to be we're going to be
going back to the same
authors and the same sources you know
those summaries of stoic ethics with
aries didymus
and um
musonius rufus
and
not muslims rufus uh um diogenes lair
taste we'll be looking at at you know
rufus epictetus
uh seneca
you know we'll talk about what cicero
has to say
all right uh rick is wisdom over other
virtues or do they have equal value yes
both
wisdom is is you could say
the first among equals right if we want
to use that phrase in a certain respect
if we want to think about it with
capital s
you know sophia or capital w wisdom
all the virtues involve wisdom in some
way and and wisdom you know this is
interesting too wisdom
just like the other virtues has its
origin in our natural uh inclinations
desires and stuff like that but it goes
beyond it and elevates us
in ways beyond even what the other three
do
you need wisdom in order for courage to
be courage for example right
uh jeremiah says two types of stoics
platonic and aristotelian
no that's completely wrong stoics are
stoics are a different different school
you know
i mean
the easiest way to look at that is look
at the anthropology right plato has a
tripartite anthropology aristotle has a
bipartite anthropology stoics don't
they have a different
anthropology so you you always want to
like look at the stoics on their own
terms just as much as with any other
school you know the the idea that
everybody's either an aristotelian or a
platonist got into the history of
philosophy through a lot of bad takes
jeremiah any thoughts on seneca's
argument for suicide
he doesn't have an argument for suicide
he has
clarifications about when suicide would
be appropriate for a person he's not
saying everybody should kill themselves
because that's what an argument for
suicide would be
seneca thinks that and this is a
consistent stoic idea that um
if things
are uh such that you know
you know life becomes unendurable
and you are you know pretty well off in
terms of developing the virtues not not
a problem you know um the the foolish
person committing suicide because you
know they lost their job or you know um
they're in a love affair and it goes
badly
um they shouldn't commit suicide but
they will commit suicide in some cases
and that's precisely how how screwed up
their their thinking is you know i mean
epictetus has this great passage
where he's talking about poverty and he
says what is it you're really worried
about being poor what is it you're
worried about
you know um is it you're worried that
you're not gonna get to eat anything or
is it you're not gonna eat eat the stuff
that you like now and people will will
kill themselves over all sorts of
things you know to avoid disgrace to
um you know uh not have their
dirty business dealings revealed or
things like that right
um
so it's there isn't a one-size-fits-all
thing about suicide for the stoics you
know obviously cato committed suicide
why because it was serving a greater
good he was not going to allow himself
to be used for propaganda purposes by a
tyrant that is julius caesar who he'd
fought against as best he could seneca
commits suicide at the order of nero why
does seneca commit suicide well because
if he hadn't
nero probably would have killed
everybody near and dear to seneca you
know
um so you know we want to be thoughtful
as we approach this you know the answer
i guess would be
um
you you have to look at the situation
and the goods and evils that that are
involved right not just for you but for
other people
and then you have to
you know prudentially make a decision
all right coffee smug for stoix our
virtue is intrinsically good because
those are things that we desire as ends
in themselves no
or is there some other reason what makes
virtuous life something we should aspire
to
um
virtues are intrinsically good they're
not intrinsically good uh because we
desire them they're we desire them
because they're intrinsically good
right even the people who are messed up
and are you know pretty badly off and
vicious still would like to think of
themselves you know the cowardly would
like to think of himself as courageous
right and can even see something
valuable there the virtues are modes of
human goodness you know they're they're
what it looks like when a human being
has developed their nature properly and
to go to efron's question you know as a
muslim my virtue is relative to god
god wants you i mean if you have any
good interpretation of
islam or christianity that isn't a pure
volunteerism god wants you to be
virtuous
and god wants you to be virtuous not
just because god wants you to be
virtuous as sort of a capricious tyrant
god wants you to be virtuous because
that's good for you and good for other
people because virtues are good
um i mean
you can read many other authors on this
think about saying augustine who says
virtue is not the good but it's
certainly like the the way that god
wants us to be you know we live in a
world where the virtues are still
combating against vices and many of the
virtues of the pagans or splendid vices
yeah that's all true
but they're still good right so
some of these are sort of like putting
the cart before the horse kind of kind
of mistakes
um virtue is what makes us live a happy
life i mean
and you can provide like very abstract
philosophical arguments for this or you
can say do you like not being screwed up
do you like being less screwed up in
your life well maybe you follow these
paths and try to cultivate these things
and you'll get to see experientially
what it's like to be less screwed up
right
so i mean i think a lot of people
overthink this um this matter of like
why should i be virtuous and and the
stoics would be perfectly fine with
saying to you after they give their
arguments
hey you don't want to be virtuous you
want to be
you know unjust you want to be cowardly
you want to be intemperate you want to
be foolish go try that out for a while
see how that works out for you and the
people around you who will say man why
can't you get your [ __ ] together
right and uh that's you know
um
sounds like there's a fire
on the way you know that's that's what
happens ernie says why is it so easy to
fall on device while virtue is difficult
to begin on the path
i wouldn't say it is i would say that
you know it's up to you and
um
[Music]
you know you can choose i mean there's a
lot of vices where you got to kind of
work at them to work your way into them
if you've got a decent enough moral
starting point i mean you know like like
all these people say nobody really wants
to buy into falsehood right um so
you know it's
i mean if you really really find it
difficult to be temperate um you're
probably kind of you're probably already
in vice right
rather than being like in a middle
position
um and you know vices promise short-term
gains and if you're motivated by those
then you're gonna have to resist that um
wisdom is part of that like wisdom think
about developing wisdom part of that is
is so
basic and simple like saying
um do i want to make the decision this
way do i want to go eat that third cake
you know
or do i want to do something else
instead
mark says part of virtues are that they
are doing good things in good ways it's
acting such as to do the best of things
the question should be why would i want
to act poorly why would i want to suck
yeah i mean that's that's
that's you know that's sort of a good
way to put it in a very basic
you know gets us right where we are kind
of uh way right
um and you know and there are
temptations but you know we're also
human beings that can choose for
ourselves um i mean part of part of
what's really hard for a lot of people
this is a little bit of a
uh
digression but we'll come back to this
is that they've got the wrong like
epictetus says dogmata right they've
been told things like you
you need to you know get the most out of
life at every moment so
you know if it's the third slice of cake
you better think short term and have
that piece of cake right now right why
should you uh put off uh you know having
it to tomorrow you know indulge yourself
today well those are dogmata right and
we didn't you know part of what we can
do is we can think about geez where did
i get these these wrong-headed ideas
about things you know think about anger
too right you get angry with people and
you're like i gotta punch that guy out
and and you know well where the hell did
that idea come from i don't know maybe
it came from your
your you know jackass dad and uncles or
the kids at school or the the stuff that
you're consuming you know through media
or
and what we what we have to do
when the stomachs really don't talk the
classic stocks don't talk about this
that much and actually neither do the to
the present-day interpreters
this is where we actually do need to
like
think about where our dogmata where our
ideas are are coming from
um
and uh
you know maybe do something like
psychotherapy right that could be a
helpful adjunct
um
coffee smug i get the idea i get the
sense from epictetus you should fulfill
your duty because that's the best thing
you could do in life are subjectively
most satisfying
that seems related to what people desire
most most people don't really desire to
do their duties
that's why they're like oh crap i've
been invited to you know this thing or
oh i got to go over to mom and dad's
place you know and hang out with them
for a while or oh i got to help a friend
move right most people aren't naturally
inclined to doing their duties
um there's a wide spectrum right so
and epictetus thinks that you know you
should fulfill your duties for a variety
of reasons because it's the right thing
to do right that's a reason because it
will on some level make you uh happy
that is being in a good you know place
where you could say i did did what i
needed to do two different reasons there
we don't always have to like try to
reduce these things down to one single
reasoning especially when the texts
don't don't bear that out
uh absurdo how can virtue and stoicism
help women fight against their erasure
from history there is no erasure from
history going on so i'm going to leave
that one right there that's just
silliness that's imprudence that's
that's the opposite of wisdom right
there if you've got those sort of
thoughts you want to start looking at
them really carefully and why you're
buying into them and why you would even
repeat them
in you know as your opportunity to
engage
with a you know thoughtful conversation
that's exactly the sort of stuff that
that stoics would say look that's that's
you know foolishness and you want to dig
that out and replace it with wisdom
ephron what are the stoics view on sex
were they against sex for pleasure
outside of having kids or any kind of
hedonism didn't they see sex or sexual
desires distraction from gaining higher
truth no that's all off base right there
so
musonius rufus actually has
you know discussions of marriage and
whether marriage keeps us from being
able to be philosophers or not
and you know part of it is producing new
little human beings but you know into
sex and intimacy is also supposed to
produce friendship and the stoics have
talked about this quite a bit you can
actually i've written about this and my
wife and i do workshops and and talks
about this uh you know uh erotic desire
romance partnered relationship stoicism
perfectly compatible with that um being
a stoic and you know participating
heavily in the hook-up culture those are
probably contradictory to each other
right but most of the people
participating in the hookup culture are
not doing so just because they're
desiring pleasure they're be it's
because they're lonely lonely people and
don't know who they are and think that
their value is measured primarily by how
many conquests they have or stuff like
that
and we could go on and on you know
there's like a whole conversation to be
had about this
pleasure is a preferred indifferent for
the stoics right
it is not something bad
it is not something intrinsically good
there's nothing wrong with enjoying
sexual pleasure uh provided that's not
screwing you up in other ways and by the
way even the epicureans
uh say you know this can often get us
into
into trouble now are the stoics against
any kind of hedonism depends on what you
mean by hedonism
if you mean the idea that life is about
enjoying pleasure as much as possible
and avoiding pain as much as possible
yeah the stoics are against that right
so are the aristotelians so are the
plaintiffs
uh even the epicureans are against other
kinds of hedonism like uh the cyrenaic
let's just party all night kind of
hedonism
if you're talking about a
proper recognition that pleasure plays a
role within a human life
and that giving other people pleasure um
can be a good thing to do might be
actually be part of our duties or
appropriate acts
well then pleasure can actually function
there it's very important to remember
that for the stoics these virtues wisdom
justice temperance courage they're not
just about like the perfect pure life
way over here
they're about all these indifference and
how we use them our bodies
our
uh emotions our pleasures and pains
those you know our wealth our reputation
those are not things that we say oh we
just don't give a [ __ ] about them at all
we use them prudently right
mark says what would be the opposing
vice to wisdom folly foolishness
um you know uh it's got it's got
different names
um
do they see ignorance as a vice they see
ignorance as as sort of a part of a vice
you could say right
i mean there's a lot of ways to be
foolish you can be foolish by being
ignorant
and you can be ignorant by having the
wrong ideas about things when you should
have better ideas you can be ignorant by
not knowing something that you should
know
we can talk about whether one is
culpable for one's ignorance or you know
whether one is just you know kind of
stuck unfortunately in a condition where
they're ignorant you know for example uh
right now in the russia ukraine conflict
it turns out that a lot of those poor
bastard russian soldiers who are digging
around chernobyl um had no idea that a
you know massive nuclear catastrophe
took place there because they hadn't
been taught about it in their
educational system
and so you know when people were like
don't dig there what are you doing
where's your your you know i don't
remember we call them mop suits in the
army you know for uh nuclear biological
chemical stuff but um
they didn't know that they should have
any of that sort of stuff that that's
one kind of ignorance the kind of
ignorance that consists in like you know
going on facebook or twitter and you
know participating in particular
communities where you're routinely being
fed misinformation to make you panicky
and you know all and then you're
reinforcing it that's a very different
kind of ignorance right and so you know
foolishness would be like the
overarching vice but it could take all
sorts of forms stubbornness you know
sticking to things when it's not the
right thing to do epictetus talks about
this a lot of people assume that
stoicism means you make a decision and
you stick with it and epictetus says
it's got to be the right decision
because otherwise you're sticking with a
bad decision aren't you you know
he's got this example of a guy who
decides that he's going to end his life
you know uh he's just not going to eat
anymore and he'll starve himself to
death and epictetus says
what's your motivation for this because
if your motivation is a good motivation
okay that's that's fine
if your motivation is just like ah you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna show those
bastards well that's stupid
and it wouldn't be good to follow
through on that resolution as a matter
of fact you should prudently
thoughtfully wisely
reconsider it you know
as a matter of fact
a lot of
behaving prudently for us you know
screwed up poor schmucks that are not
the sage is going to consist a lot of
the time in saying
oh man i was wrong how do i fix this
how do i get myself back on track right
that that is that is indeed part of
prudence sometimes prudence consists in
saying
wow i am not as smart as i thought i was
i better find a way to figure out how to
be
smarter going forward and how to fix the
things that i screwed up because of my
dumbness in the past so
any other questions comments uh
issues about wisdom
sub-virtues
natural human desire to
learn things know things understand
things
or other stoic related matters
while i'm waiting for people to write
i'll i'll remind you that we're going to
be doing another thing so ephron says is
japanese philosophy similar to stoicism
that that you can't really say that
because is there a japanese philosophy
no there's a whole bunch of different
japanese philosophers
so i mean i suppose in so far as its
philosophy it's similar to statism but
that's about as far as you can go
um ac would stoicism always be the
method to resolve life issues um
that's a good question so
i am not myself somebody who described
my myself as just a stoic right i use
stoicism
for um
different things sort of like cicero you
know i'm an eclectic i i take big parts
of systems
uh and then i
bring them together in ways that work so
i mean there are some people who try to
use stoicism as the single method to
resolve life issues and then they often
get themselves into trouble often
because they don't fully understand
they're not reading you know like the
stoic text the way they ought to be
they're reading some popular literature
on it and then they get into situations
and you know it's not covered well and
then they get all pissed off and then
they go into like a stoicism facebook
group and you know complain about that
um i think stoicism like many other
things can be successfully brought in
but you have to prudently consider which
ideas you want to
keep and consider
um barles is there a place for regret in
stoic philosophy yeah
there certainly is um it's viewed as a
negative emotion that you don't want to
have but if you do have it then you
probably want to figure out why you're
feeling it and start looking at your
dogmata
and the decisions that you made and you
know you try to try to wean yourself
away from it right
uh mark smith what's the next virtue
deep dive good question i want to say
that it's ver i want to say that it's
justice
but i don't remember
quite if that's yeah it is it is justice
um and then we're gonna do temperance
and courage
uh
the following month
um coffee smug do you think epictetus is
a moral intuitionist or is goodness
reducible to some natural property
no and no um
i think those those sort of uh isms and
you know abstract classifications are
kind of off base and not particularly
useful for understanding robust uh
virtue ethics
all right ac says that one again strikes
the point of critical thinking i'm not
sure what that means
um
mass acts says how did stoicism
influence cognitive science it didn't
influence cognitive science it primarily
influenced the cognitive approaches in
psychotherapy which are not the same
thing as cognitive science as a case
where you don't want to be misled by
them using the same word
cyrillic writing i can't really read it
but do you recommend seneca to those who
liked epictetus's works yeah i recommend
all the stoics i mean
um if you want to know about stoicism
there is absolutely no substitute for
spending a lot of time
reading epictetus's works that the
encoradian and the discourses
and reading seneca's works which
includes at a minimum reading seneca's
letters to achilles but i would also
recommend reading seneca's other
treatises as as well
um i mean if you wanna if you wanna
claim that you're like practicing
stoicism understanding stoicism that
ought to be like the
you know that ought to be like the most
central thing it's fine to read you know
other
20th century 21st century stuff you know
massimo's how to be a stoic
you know um
decent good literature on it don't don't
waste your time on the schmaltzy not not
particu not particularly good stuff
but you got to be spending your time
with the original thinkers you know
um so you know that that's that's really
important
um
ac is there any connection between
stoicism and psychology i think we
address that yes there's connections
between stoicism and the cognitive
approaches like rational motive behavior
therapy and things going on from there
z is there a hype about stoicism in the
first quarter of the 21st century what
do you think are the reasons for it i
mean i don't know what a hype is there's
like a lot of like
superficial interest in stoicism there's
a lot of people
using stoicism wrongly to like you know
uh try to sell sell you coaching things
or stuff like that a lot of these people
don't actually know much about stoicism
unfortunately and then they you know if
that's what you that's your encounter
with stoicism then you're like well
these these stoics are kind of jerks
but there's a lot of really really great
work on stoicism so you want to kind of
stick to the the people who are doing
good work on it
zachary are there any relations between
social epistemology and stoic wisdom the
vices of fake news i mean i don't think
you have to call it social epistemology
you could call it epistemology
applied to social matters you know yeah
fake news is i mean if you're buying
into fake news you're foolish and you're
misinformed and um if you're tell if
you're calling real news fake news
you're also
a vicious person you're foolish you know
uh sure there's all sorts of connections
to that uh thank you very much we don't
study stoicism detail at my faculty i
will dive into seneca well this is this
actually brings up a great point again
this is the person with cyril cyrillic
name i should learn to
to be able to read it so i could
actually
you know sound out the letters
stoicism is not going to be taught as
such
in a lot of philosophy faculties and
it's one of those things that like if
you want to study it nothing holds you
back
all the
not all but nearly all of the ancient
stoic works are available for you online
you know we live in a 20th 21st century
internet world right so if you want to
read seneca's letters they're there in
wikisource right i mean you can order
them and buy them and i i you know i say
it's good to own books right
but
you probably have to do that on your own
but there's all these great resources
out there and there's all sorts of
groups that you can meet up with the
stoic fellowship keeps like a running
list and map of all the different
meetup groups that you can get involved
in
um let's say coffee smug which modern
scholarly work and virtue ethics
reflects stoicism the most that's a good
question um you know a lot of the stuff
that's coming from an
either abstract virtue ethics thing
where they don't actually know what
virtue ethics is because they don't read
aristotle or the stoics or things like
that they just kind of blather on about
how it's different than consciousness or
utilitarianism put that all that crap
aside right
the neo-aristotelian stuff and aleister
mcintyre would be kind of like front and
center in that
they don't really understand stoicism
that well
a long wrote a really awesome piece
in response to mcintyre's after virtue
about that
that's easily findable on the internet
someday i'll probably do a video about
that that that piece or a couple videos
because it's so excellent
um julia annas somebody who does know
the
stoics um
you know major virtue ethicist
uh martha nussbaum not into the stoics
but knows the stoics you know um
and then we have stoic virtue ethicists
like christopher gill who's writing a
whole book on stoic virtue ethics
um
i would say if you can if you can get
your way through lawrence becker's a new
stoicism that's a virtue ethics although
it's that's a tough book that's a
difficult one to to read
um
coffee smug video about stoic meta
ethics would be most awesome i don't do
meta ethics because i i think that meta
ethics doesn't really exist as such i
think every meta ethics is really
a substantive ethics
and i'm in the minority there
chris pryor do you have a favorite
passage from any stoic work which you
have memorized and pull out of your
daily life when needed i have no
favorites i do have plenty of um this is
a good question this and this this
actually goes to the topic of wisdom
so you know i've used this term dogmata
a couple times and a dog a dogma
is something that's like a judgment or
an opinion it can also be something
that's like a maxim that you say to
yourself so when you're reading
epictetus and epictetus over and over
again will say have this ready at hand
when you meet this difficulty or keep
this ever in mind
and then he says something all of those
all those little nuggets or quotes
as people like to call them
are the dogmata that we're supposed to
use when we run into stuff so
i don't i don't use the pithy quotes
like you know when i get angry i say
anger is a temporary madness or stuff
like that but i i do apply the teachings
to what i'm going through you know
sometimes successfully often
unsuccessfully right
uh and and you you the more that you
study this is why it's so important to
read the primary text the more you're
stacking your head with this stuff so
instead of you know some quote by some
second-rate you know popularizer of
stoicism you actually have epictetus or
seneca or musonius rufus ready to help
you out when you need some help
ephron did the stoics talk about
mysticism they did not the stoics are
not mystics so
um not not important at all that's
actually one thing i like about them
because i'm not into mysticism my myself
so
uh we're a little bit over time but i
can take a few more questions if anybody
wants to ask anything and then i have
unfortunately i have to exercise the
virtue of fortitude and make myself do
the thing i dislike the most about being
an academic and that is
grading i have a lot of grading to catch
up on
today and i'm not happy with myself
somebody asked that question about
regret right so
i regret
not having gotten the grading done
earlier this week because on a sunday
afternoon
that's what i'm stuck doing so mark says
hi and bye hey mark good to see you here
um
[Music]
uh z is conformity uh an obstacle to
stoic wisdom if conformity means
something like um following you know
whatever your society is telling you
it's keeping your head down that's
actually a kind of cowardice most likely
right
from a stoic position so yeah that would
be an obstacle to stoic wisdom
um
[Music]
so yeah that that could be a a real
problem commoditat i don't i don't know
is that like the a german
rendering of conformity
um
ac says thank you so much for your kind
response you're very welcome
um
all right well let's let's call this to
to an end like i mentioned
uh two weeks from now we'll talk about
justice we'll do a deep dive into it
uh bringing in the text and then doing
you know chat afterwards and then the
next month we will do
um
[Music]
courage and temperance i also do so pay
attention you know if you follow me on
social media or in youtube or things
like that
i do have a
workshop coming up uh
a free workshop on a new platform that
will happen on may 1st
about um stoic practices coming from
epictetuses and caridian
and uh that should be pretty pretty cool
so
keep your eyes open for that otherwise
i'll see all of you and
those of you who are having
nighttime have a good night have a good
evening those of you in the morning have
a good morning everybody else have a
good rest of your day and i'll see you
later on